The ISIS hostage triangle, I'll call it,
that involve a Japanese journalist, a
terrorist, as well as a Jordanian pilot
has taken an taken an interesting twist,
a delay, if you will. We're going to
discuss that coming up. Meantime, here's
what the White House had to say.
But how is what the Jordanians are
talking about doing any different than
what the United States did to get the
release of Burgd Doll releasing
prisoners held at Guantanamo Bay to the
Taliban which is clearly a terrorist
organization.
Sure. Uh as you know uh this was highly
discussed um at the time and prisoner
swaps are traditional end of conflict um
uh interaction that that happens. Um, as
the war in Afghanistan wound down, um,
we felt like it was the appropriate
thing to do.
The White House trying to backpedal a
little bit on prisoner exchanges that
happened. Uh, the conversation went a
little bit further in that they said the
Taliban wasn't a terrorist organization.
Long and short. But regardless, we're
sitting in a situation where there's a
generic Jordanian Jordanian uh pilot uh
that's being held captive, a Japanese
journalist, and one of his associates
has already been beheaded presumably uh
dead and then an uh a terrorist as well.
So joining us, Robert Spencer is the
director of Jihad Watch. Robert, it's
getting to be a complicated situation
with lots of ramifications, isn't it?
Yes, it is. Well, this is because the
Islamic State keeps changing its
demands. First, it wanted 200 million.
Then, there was the deal that they would
release the Jordanian pilot and
presumably also the Japanese hostage in
exchange for this jihad mass murderer,
Sajjida Arushawi. But now they're saying
you have to release Sajjida by uh what
was it? Midnight or uh the Jordanian
pilot will be killed with no mention
whatsoever that they're going to release
anybody. Uh right now the situation in
Jordan though seems to be from the
reports I've read that there's broad
support to do this exchange. Are you
hearing the same things?
Yeah, absolutely. And that's of course
because there's broad support for the
kind of jihad attacks that Sajja Arishwi
has has been responsible for. And so
they figure well she shouldn't be in
prison anyway and uh they can get the
pilot back and write this wrong and
everybody's happy. The problem is this
is somebody who's a trained killer. She
has killed many people and she would
almost certainly kill many more if she's
released.
Okay, so that's the that's the hard
part. So the Americans can't support it
even though they've done exchanges in
the past.
Well, you know, the exchanges in the
past were not very well advised either.
I mean, look, Bo Bergd Doll is
reportedly about to be charged with
desertion. And so, and and of course, as
soon as the exchange was announced for
Bergd Doll that all his uh his comrades
in the military, in the division that he
was in began to come out with these
stories saying they knew he was a
deserter, they knew he had converted to
Islam and joined the Taliban. And now,
uh they the United States exchanged five
trained jihad terror leaders back to the
Taliban for him. And now he's going to
be charged with desertion. You got to
wonder what the what was that all about
except as part of Obama's ongoing
attempt to empty Guantanamo out entirely
and close it down.
Yeah. And but the Americans are saying
do as I say and not as I do in that
particular case. Where are the Japanese
in this whole equation? They've said
that they won't pony up the money, but
where else?
Yeah. Well, they seem to be open to the
idea of a prisoner exchange, and I think
that is just as ill advised as giving
the Islamic State money. Uh look, it's
demonstrable that uh European
governments by paying ransoms for
hostages have essentially been financing
al-Qaeda and the Islamic State wants in
on that action. They wanted hundreds of
millions for James Foley. Now they
wanted 200 million for the Japanese
hostages and the Jordanian pilot. And
the thing is that uh it's it's wise of
governments to stop giving into those
demands. But if they exchange these
prisoners then the effect is even worse
because as I say Saja Arshawi Rishawi is
very likely to kill again. And so how
many more people are going to be killed
just to secure the release of these
hostages?
Well in fact Robert it's kind of
tragically ironic that France is one of
the people that has been paying ransoms.
Yeah. Absolutely. So France has been
financing essentially the jihad that
struck them so forcefully in the last
few weeks. And no question about it,
Robert. We're going to take a quick
break. We'll come back and continue this
discussion.
We're not going to say okay to
terrorists and just bend to their
threats. The United States is not going
to do that. The c the government of
Jordan is not going to do that. We need
to degrade and defeat ISIL so that this
is not a threat that is facing the world
in the future. So no, we can't as
governments bend to their threats, but
we can have compassion for the pain and
suffering of of families around the
world.
Yeah, that shuffling here is the White
House and the Americans backpedaling a
little bit on some of the statements
they've made in the past. Robert Spencer
is still with us. Robert, here's the
thing that I'm looking at. I'm looking
at, you know, we know there's a problem
in Syria and that's ongoing. Iraq
problem ongoing. There are all kinds of
players, big players in the area. Saudi
Arabia, uh, Israel, Iran, Turkey, but
the one that's in the focus right now is
Jordan to my way of thinking. Where do
they stand? Are they stable right now?
Jordan is uh stable, but it's it's right
on the edge. What we have in Jordan is
of course the uh kingdom that has been
there for decades. And there are the
pressures in Jordan from groups like the
Muslim Brotherhood and also sympathizers
with the Islamic State to overthrow the
monarchy and to establish an Islamic
state there, a Sharia ruled government.
And so far the kingdom has been able to
deal with these uh these elements pretty
well. But there are whole towns, whole
cities that have declared open sympathy
for the Islamic State within Jordan. And
uh these quarters are going to be heard
from. The Islamic State of course is
right next door and has designs on the
whole region. They've announced, they've
even published maps where Jordan is part
of their so-called caliphate. And so uh
the Jordanians have to tread very
carefully in regard to this. If they
don't for example release Sajjida al
Arashawi then they might face
significant protests within Jordan
itself and that is a factor that they
have to take into consideration.
So the probability is that they will
release her. It's just a question of
when. Yeah, I think so. A question of
when and how. They want to secure that
they get the pilot back safely. And of
course, the Japanese are hoping that
they will also be able to free their
hostage. And all these things are up in
the air now with the latest from the
Islamic State, which offers absolutely
nothing in return for Sajida.
Well, other than the two prisoners that
they've got currently.
No, they they didn't offer anything. In
the last communicate, they said you have
to release her by midnight or we will
kill the pilot. They didn't say anything
about releasing anybody.
Okay, that's that's hardly a negotiation
then if only one party's speaking.
Well, yeah, but that's the way it is
with Islamic supremacists. It's all
unilateral. You do their bidding or they
will kill you. That's how they operate.
They're not they're into negotiations if
they can see that they work to their own
advantage, but only then.
Does it work to their advantage if they
kill the pilot and there's an uprising?
uh you're you're talking about Jordan as
if it's at the breaking point if there's
an uprising in Jordan.
That is a consideration that they also
have to take into account. But they also
operate according to another principle
that's enunciated in the Quran. The that
the the believers have the
responsibility to strike terror into the
hearts of the enemies of Allah. And
that's chapter 8 60 of the Quran. And so
they may be calculating that by killing
the pilot they'll frighten the
Jordanians into submission rather than
cause them to rise up in anger.
Is there loyalty um within Jordan to the
king es especially amongst the military
forces?
Are they likely to be spooked for
instance?
Uh no I don't think that the military
forces will be. I think that they're
hoping that the people will be and that
that will shake the uh monarchy's
loyalty, its base among the people and
that then they can exploit that.
Yeah. So there's for them uh there's
nothing to be lost, if you will, by
killing the pilot.
Oh, absolutely. That's right. I mean, it
may be that they'll calculate that
they'll do better in Jordan in the long
run if they let him go. And see, these
are the the the possibilities under
Islamic law. Islamic law says if you
take a hostage, you can kill him, you
can ransom him in a trade for money or
another prisoner. You can enslave him or
free him outright. And you do what's
best for Islam. You make the decision on
that basis. So the Islamic State
operates strictly according to Islamic
law. They're going to make the decision
to free their hostages or kill them
based on what they think will be to
their advantage in the long run. But we
have to get over in the west the idea
that they're thinking the way we are
with humanitarian considerations that
means nothing to them. And their
considerations of real politic are quite
different from ours because they are not
afraid to use terror. And in fact they
are commanded in their view to use
terror as a means to gain power and hold
it.
Okay. Now apply the same principles. I I
I now get where you're going with the
Jordanian um pilot. Apply the same
principles with the Japanese journalist.
Well, it's the same thing with him
really that uh they will free him if
it's to their advantage. They wanted
money. It doesn't look as if they're
going to get money and so then they want
the exchange of the prisoner. If they
believe that they cannot get Sajjida
Aishawi without freeing Kenji Gooto,
then they'll free him. But if they think
that they can get away with getting
Sajida without freeing Kenji, then he
will likely be killed because that also
will strike terror into the hearts of
the enemies of Allah. Okay. Then uh what
will the global response be? I mean the
Japanese obviously will will uh respond
appropriately. Where will the Americans
respond? Do you think?
I I think that the Islamic State knows
that Barack Obama is not going to do
anything significant against it. Uh
there'll be more air strikes. There'll
be more angry rhetoric, but there won't
be anything effective done. He does not
want to get involved in another ground
war in Iraq after making it a lynch pin
of his presidency to get us out of one.
Yeah, I suspect you were right, Robert.
Thank you so much. You've shed a lot of
light on this situation. Appreciate it.
Thank you.
Robert Spencer joining us. He's a
director of Jihad Watch. She knows the
inner workings of how that all works.